I just really started reading as much as
I could get my hands on in the financial
markets and one thing led to another and
it really kind of early on I was like
okay so who's the smartest investor out
there what books have they read what do
they think about and so it led me to
warren buffett I kind of became obsessed
with anything and everything Warren
Buffett related you can probably see the
security analysis book that back there
behind me I had the whole thing tabbed
out and highlighted and just totally
nerd it out on the thing and you know
2008 hits and learned real fast that
there was a lot of parts to the
investing story that I still didn't
understand through that through that
event and just made me dig in even more
and so through the years I mean I've
been at it for probably two decades
nearly at this point just investing
personally and reading as much as I can
possibly get my hands on and then just
studying anybody who has made lots of
money in the market and just trying to
understand how their brain ticks and how
they've been able to pick it apart and
here we are
so yeah that's I'd say that's probably
the the Cliff Notes version for sure how
did you originally come across a Bitcoin
and kind of crypto measure doing that
study you know I uh I was not a macro
person at all for the longest time and
believe it or not it's kind of funny
because I read Tony Robbins book oh god
I can't even remember the name of he's
done two of them the first one I think
it was just called money master the game
was the first one and in the book he
talks about Ray Dalio a lot and I'd
really not studied Ray Dalio didn't know
really anything about his approach but
Tony was just I mean pumping him so hard
in this book as if he was the master of
everything right and Here I am as a
Warren Buffett person and just you know
the the propaganda from Buffett is that
if it's macro related you just ignore it
and you just look at the individual
company and it's kind of this ground-up
analysis and macro is too hard to
understand so you just ignore it
and so Dalio I was just kind of blown
away how much Tony Robbins was talking
him up so I started reading everything I
could get my hands on on revalue like
how does he have his opinion well why is
it structured this way why does he have
gold in his portfolio that's nuts
because any Warren Buffett person will
tell you Gold's worthless so like all
these ideas that were just they were so
counter to everything that I believed up
to that point and I loved it because it
was counter to what I thought and if you
study anybody who's made a lot of money
in the markets they they absolutely love
it when somebody has the opposite
opinion of them and they want to
understand all the reasons why so that
was me I was like okay I just tried to
read everything I can on Ray Dalio next
thing I know Ray had posted and it's not
available online anymore but luckily I
got the PDF and I printed this thing
before it was taken offline but I mean
his whole there's a really famous video
that Ray Dalio did it's called how the
economic machine works it's a thirty
minute video I would tell you that video
that thirty minute video is probably
more valuable than anything you'll
probably ever learn in a business school
economics class ever and I truly mean
that if you don't believe me pull up the
video watch it for yourself and I'm
pretty much sure that that's probably
the conclusion you'll draw at the end of
it well anyway Ray had a I'd say it was
a it's on the Shelf back there to it
probably 200 to 250 page manual that was
the text behind that video it went into
a lot more detail than that video and I
studied the living hell out of this
thing
I mean just read it and read it again
and then started digging into like all
these ideas that Ray had and so I would
tell you that as I look at my investing
approach today I would tell you it's
probably 50% Dalio and 50% Buffett as
far as the fundamentals maybe you know
10% you could shave off to some other
folks but in in general I'd say it's a
50/50 split between those two investors
as to how I think about markets and so
that's how I started getting in
where I started getting interested in
Bitcoin is because I'm looking at all
the things from the Dalio approach and
I'm saying this is this is pretty darn
scary now that I'm seeing the world from
a completely different vantage point and
all these macro factors and you've got
these 80 year credit cycles which I was
not even aware of as a value investor
with a Buffett style approach but when
you start looking at those charts and
you see the 10 year Treasury that went
up for 40 years and now it's gone down
for 40 years and now it's at zero
percent and well what does that mean
well we can get into all the what all
that means but as a person who never
looked at that I can tell you it was
pretty alarming for me probably oh boy
five years ago I'd say is whenever I the
light swells more than that because I
started getting into Bitcoin
it was probably 2014 when I started
reading all that and it quickly led me
to Bitcoin and I made my first purchase
at the start of the second quarter in
2015 for Bitcoin